Domo.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] went to buy some legislative seats.
The Cio
who's off peak around opinion where it's you gay Camiel Oh,
we don't have to wash the location.
The
[inaudible] [inaudible] so,
so on the navy by middle.
Totally cool.
Oh,
Tommy [inaudible] Yoshi,
they could email you go to Europe.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Smith.
On Monday,
he goes,
[inaudible] don't want to take deal
with a pink around identity.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] is your sister's hair.
It seems heads up from yonder with the deal.
[inaudible]
hello?
I said,
what did the rock star video
[inaudible] [inaudible] so as long as she's Day,
you'd say you don't have to.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] talking day.
He called [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] now Marianna guy.
Just hangup g rubbishing though.
It has all to [inaudible] to do
you also get a user to one
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] southern and they could get off target.
Young Taco bell hadn't gotten email.
Hudson
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] as a terrible,
hadn't got power and walked and got,
hadn't gone towards your goals.
[inaudible] toning and meet the hands of [inaudible] and [inaudible] [inaudible]
or [inaudible] [inaudible] or in the day to
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] the [inaudible].
You can,
I should've got,
I wasn't
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a total loss of resourcing.
It should take all your optimize seriously when you put it as an autocrat
session.
There you go.
Oh my gosh.
It's,
I listen to me that they,
you know,
keep up with us in about
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
talk.
Ooh,
me pay going.
You could show something on [inaudible] or [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
take it to tuck officer
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Sosa.
You think [inaudible] could I saw the peanut
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] it's hard to know.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] opposite or national?
They were they teaching,
you know,
Puerto Rico,
who will learn?
She doesn't know about it.
On my own.
Take on [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] cause of tools on
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] you're shimmy occur.
She needed to live.
I said they're in the big data.
Hadoop and spark helps us.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] oil in Nicole [inaudible].
That's how bio as a youtube tutorial in [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] Nicola Youtube.
Youtube is a concept called,
yeah,
Youtube.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] slime.
Sorry.
I'm going to slam it's slay me.
You'll keep
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] the update that when you go
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
so do the opponent new on 10 or [inaudible]
Oh,
you look at some types of tickets.
So I would do a
good
platform.
Digital content.
Dawn,
you took it out on t you don't go [inaudible] on an [inaudible]
teaming.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
around the usage data.
And so you two month take him governors be the get that wasn't going well.
How about you?
[inaudible] petco thrown a near [inaudible] Hennen there.
It didn't take a crunchy [inaudible]
cool.
Here's a Taylor orientation.
Who needs a [inaudible]?
[inaudible].
What do they use that is are they are,
cause I take our common character kitty,
the [inaudible] [inaudible]
total overkill.
Google even on Sasha [inaudible] tuna [inaudible]
cousins,
cousins.
Hackathons are as a gauge or
[inaudible] [inaudible] you should go.
Got Bored and go
[inaudible] issue.
Linda
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
oh.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] injured recruit one go to
[inaudible] [inaudible]
got Cobra Golf.
[inaudible] Cobalamin
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Queen Secret
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
he owns over auto.
Coming to
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] can they
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] our toolboxes in Borneo,
I you guys,
is that they have actually one year then our job.
Tell him I need,
I'm telling in the net.
I'm pleased about that.
Diana,
Danika,
and they tell a Nigga in the day and a guy,
I realize there's so much of an idol.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] where you look at contents,
your [inaudible] where content
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] so you don't get it to be with Tousley give it tells me.
Yeah,
you're done.
You come work on their pipe.
Costar and then she'll be like go cause she lettered panel to come on panel
words go could go to your opponents.
Have the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] jr he children's also.
You shouldn't go here.
Comments on each onions.
A manual I
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] under a paper.
One human voices.
So don't matter what the topic was,
putting you equal.
I thought the payback on you and your payback on it too.
When you tell a month 20 each one on Wednesday,
I can't go off this.
You gotta cut the bar that I get that each other [inaudible] some now who know?
Where do I say?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Nica Taurus.
[inaudible]
you can touch with about the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] to about two potato honey.
She belonged to that.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hm?
Tony [inaudible] just because on the opposite,
come on,
come on.
My teaching and
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] you get to go with,
it's on the nun kids.
Okay,
so good.
[inaudible] was he older?
Do Loan,
I'm muddy issue.
Well,
you don't go [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] come.
You don't
come telling me though.
[inaudible]
or [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] pattern.
[inaudible] good.
Okay.
All
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] it was a moderate high tepco.
[inaudible] [inaudible] or [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] the TV in there.
It got boxing.
You don't want any oil?
Could
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] take off.
You'll come out on,
what would he,
I got,
did you get done as well?
He,
yeah,
he got
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] noodle goose and Kia.
[inaudible] [inaudible] take on my Nigga.
[inaudible] each you want to shift song?
Oh,
go out and go.
Just like you said.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] cooker or standard single call that term
[inaudible] [inaudible]
she done?
Yes,
I'm puking,
puking and then,
hmm.
Uh,
woke up.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] she didn't create [inaudible] [inaudible] then the road
that
you can do to get people don't do,
that's wrong.
Paul Hutton,
z
honeymoon
Krugel he's 32
get you on Parker [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible] or [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] or [inaudible] or plastic day or obesity.
It's all public,
and
I'll probably see it turns Shem [inaudible]
take yoga off.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] per se.
[inaudible]
they won the city.
Then he got cookies.
Cookies.
I have to say
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I told candy crush question.
Okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a [inaudible] and they are
[inaudible] [inaudible]
to God.
So you can just take us off.
[inaudible] Poo Pourri is it
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] she hadn't told him.
You get to mom.
How do you get bored with it?
And she got,
she gets out of you.
Do me.
So [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] the
[inaudible] [inaudible] which is okay.
It's
good.
It was
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
or panels or a [inaudible] or [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and in the criminal Bloomberg was how many
hundred eating [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] up guys have your money so to
okay,
you
guys are going in there.
Let's let him
or [inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
you don't say
[inaudible]. [inaudible] why you did
he say he by his whole
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
telling that
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] again,
what the hunger,
um,
patients I'm supposing to do.
Cool.
Cuddle Gay.
Could you go,
come down Doug [inaudible] got to go to
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] it's high.
You get paid on the [inaudible] dot com to hug a dark room.
Still components.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] you were Peterson.
[inaudible] [inaudible] to pick up the cycle.
What?
I started there?
Yeah.
Give it your [inaudible].
Could you go
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] cool.
[inaudible] [inaudible] by to the identity toenail instead of
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] she got a time on the one that gets in and day.
[inaudible] can I solve
the by
[inaudible] [inaudible] Moodle there.
How much closer?
She said.
Well,
there is so good by the the building character.
This has all the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] judo around was when she ran [inaudible] Eco
[inaudible] pattern [inaudible] cause I'm sorry,
George,
around Uba.
[inaudible] could you hear us all?
Tutorage a Pokemon corrupt cut.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] on,
I'm on you today.
I know.
You got to know I'm on,
I'm on.
I'm on [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Tomas,
if there's hanging a table,
we'll do [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] pop components you there when we were
taller,
they get shipped to Catawba.
Yoga is [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] it comes on with that.
Do you do about that?
The
[inaudible] cause you don't wash on day.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] she's [inaudible] and chicken soup kitchens.
You too.
[inaudible] they
tackled at the [inaudible].
Ooh.
[inaudible] he didn't wanna eat through its
cutting your,
when it gets what mobile was wholly piece Sinica you don't have to be good
offshore oil.
Taco Paul.
The other day,
the huddle Collegia Nyo this was at a kitchen on the wall with the,
what's it?
The money style.
Cool.
Tim in the polar on day one day and the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] this is a new email.
Okay.
We're going to be young.
That's how we still thought that he got the Yo young number talk or when should
each party much you each time,
you know,
it goes.
Hello?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or imagine the McCord.
Only thing is the [inaudible] the good.
She's good.
Now you can send me on
[inaudible]. [inaudible] it's a cop.
Since school hadn't gone right.
Toxicants intervene.
How we go.
Sorry.
[inaudible] the top is a slower than brand.
Gotten the test.
I Sung type I collagen [inaudible] who?
Tomas [inaudible] the unity,
but then [inaudible] Ooh,
she can timeline a [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] morning.
[inaudible] [inaudible] a part of your new,
so they can see the apartment.
Hope to follow when you're a man.
So the kids got [inaudible]
some look to you got to know when you're scanning.
Rocky Barney.
Coleen Uga.
Mm.
Or [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] demeanor,
contents,
and I don't
get shitty oxide.
Then you turn you on top of tall [inaudible] Ukrainian traumatized cattle.
Okay.
They don't want [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] Joe [inaudible] Joe,
because my [inaudible] gym talk to other and [inaudible].
She said any car cause what?
Poser Readerber it was in
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] could you go boo?
Two boys go
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] youtube [inaudible] and immune
z.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and [inaudible] and they use him to start to
read
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] then
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and
[inaudible].
Touch your dog on there.
Who is [inaudible]? [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] they have cooked the
other Amazon.
They are single.
There's a second month in the world.
Take [inaudible] hello
eating popcorn.
And the titanic was a manager,
Chris or mark humble [inaudible] Pico ubd when somebody somewhere,
etc. In Chicago.
So I just,
she has a,
she's a culture.
No,
you'd be,
someone says [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] we'll do the number of demandware by law and Alana and
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] so I got in there.
But your mom [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] to the [inaudible] econ Arma cotton
community Galatia.
They got from your urine.
Yoshimi how about in the,
in Kansas?
[inaudible] watching [inaudible] but now they got one of
Kenya orange and they're talking about the Tobi data.
You Ain't got the woman Chris
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] suppose Jose cause harm.
It's who I am.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
I watch parent.
It's okay.
[inaudible]
can you tell me you're getting [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] we talked pink anemia or Latte community
reduces cortisol or the Caribbean.
[inaudible] now though.
Yeah,
you get to 10 can I turn and they sit there and then [inaudible] me.
[inaudible] de
[inaudible] [inaudible]
tiny
song is
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] keep track it at the show.
She came out of [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] she gets home [inaudible] and [inaudible]
then she need current Hermia and then she literature go home mill.
He [inaudible] say I took a powder coating.
Here they are.
They're more than your money's still cautious.
Tara was in Ankara.
Has a,
it was a good thing to my committee.
Mania.
[inaudible] Huh?
Towing guy was from one [inaudible].
How uptick is Hong Kong when your man
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] when you
got to,
it's a cookie.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
those hung up on me.
Usually when the teacher took you,
took the teacher.
Hm.
Gouda communication about what we're talking about.
Tequil tell me telling you this whole [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] so you don't get that in the
near [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] was a 100 pictures.
You don't know your [inaudible].
Hmm?
Kockler [inaudible] hello?
[inaudible]
Ooh,
good.
Some days you don't eat,
you don't usually go to
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] not only
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
we could tell.
Cool.
Good talking to you.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
total cause harm.
Yeah.
Quick your question
at
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] you don't come on down and talk to you.
Your smell,
your
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] a party.
Papa
comes out of it.
They take up
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] how did you see Nan
to
come?
Tell me though.
[inaudible]
it lets up be extreme sports.
[inaudible] telling me that.